tom brady's story okay can you please
you want to do a tom brady story
the economist is demanding the
sportswear are we going to do tom brady
this woman does not want to do it by the
way daniel stole all my notes on the
economy that she was talking about
earlier she like looked at my paper that
five-minute soliloquy she went on that
she was yours it was your nose
unbelievable i don't i'm not joking
plagiarizing anything
okay tom brady
tom brady gifts bucks fan one bitcoin
for giving back 600 touchdown ball this
is a sports illustrated story buccaneers
fan byron kennedy received quite the
haul for return of football involved in
tom brady 600 touchdown pass on sunday
including signed memorabilia and season
tickets to tampa home games and brady
had one more gift in mind for kennedy on
monday brady said he also gifted kennedy
one bitcoin during an appearance on
monday night football with peyton
manning and eli manning now perhaps that
doesn't sound like much out of context
but brady's uh gift actually comes with
a pretty hefty price tag current bitcoin
price sixty thousand dollars yet it
seems as though kennedy prefers
something other than a uh financial
reward the bucks fan said the ultimate
wish is to play around the golfer brady
perhaps the goat will take kennedy up on
the request after clinching eight his
eighth super bowl in february i mean
listen i like that yeah the ball itself
is fine ken golden came back and he said
this is a five hundred thousand dollar
ball
can can i can i be the caddy
right please you know what i think tom
brady he is a completely different
person now and the fact that he escaped
the prison camp that he was in for 20
years under that dictator that nut job
coach that can't win without him why are
you such a big fan of him and my dad
backs me up what did he do to you now
you know what you guys that is the easy
way out for all of you but he's 17 games
under 500 yeah how dare all of you i
think brady was drinking on monday night
i really do i don't like the red sox
either fyi okay well i'll get started
all boston sports so monday tuesday's
the off day in the nfl brady calls into
that show on monday night for peyton and
the boys you know he was having a
cocktail or two that night but with the
shackles off he is just a completely
different person and i think brady needs
to be an inspiration to everybody
because he literally is showing if you
want to operate at peak efficiency
physically mentally there is a way to do
it buy his book there's a road map
there's if you want to invest the time
and the energy and the dedication it
takes you can operate like that at the
age of 44. he's going to be the mvp this
year you know and i'll give you this
little anecdote when
he was a rookie his first year out of
michigan when he was a nobody i was the
sports anchor at fox in boston i was in
that locker room once a week in the
locker room i maybe i saw him three
times maybe i glanced at him once he was
irrelevant you wouldn't think of talking
to him you wouldn't think of looking
twice he wasn't the starting quarter
best friend right i've missed a great
opportunity there it's just unbelievable
how he's evolved
he could be here with us now seriously
he's gonna be calling in right now we'll
give you a couple weeks no i don't want
[Laughter]
no i think the other thing which was
interesting about this was that you
mentioned as well that ken golden was
saying easily 500 000 for the for the
football um in the article it said that
there's 28 there's 28 baseball players
who've hit a 500 plus home run club but
there's not even anyone who's remotely
close to the 600 touchdowns
puts him in a right completely legal
because you're thinking really he's got
so many mementos so many monumental
occasions and records and stats why does
that one matter but you're right no one
will touch that 600 touchdowns no until
the 700th right which will happen no and
and obviously i was reading there was a
whole bunch of things the other fan got
two two signed jerseys one helmet uh he
got mike evans game jersey signed cleats
two season tickets for the rest of the
season and uh and then there was one
other thing he got he's gonna he's gonna
sit in the suite with brady for a game
or with his family and then he got a 1
000 the first thing they offered him was
the one thousand dollar gift card into
the team first of all first of all first
of all just so you know the charity buzz
i don't know if you've heard of charity
buzz.com these guys going they'll say
hey have dinner with bill clinton for
300 000 have this have that have this
500 000 you could have sold the ball
great yeah you get a round of golf with
brady what is that worth no to a guy
that's actually a brady fan this guy
that's like priceless yeah priceless
that's it that's what i'm saying so so
so i like because a lot of people were
coming out saying you know he shouldn't
give them all back etcetera etcetera he
said himself though it's the right
decision like this means more to him
than to me and he had power to this kid
was raised properly precisely more power
to him there are a lot of parents in
america
teaching their children to be
independent
i totally agree i totally agree we're
from the same camp so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye
[Music]